for the first time in days Hong Kong on
Tuesday was free of protests and free of
canisters of tear gas instead words were
being fired in Beijing a spokesman for
the Hong Kong office of China's
government condemned what he called the
protesting thugs and promised they'd be
punished
we are Gaga hue I would like to warn all
these criminals don't even misjudge the
situation a mistake our restraints for
weakness Kim don't even duress tomates a
firm resolve in the immense strength of
the central government in the people of
the whole country to maintain Hong
Kong's prosperity and stability and
safeguard the fundamental interests of
the nation in Hong Kong representatives
of the protesters were asked whether
they thought China's army the PLA could
be deployed from their base in the
territory the police's news conference
was interrupted by a protest from Hong
Kong journalists who accuse them that
heavy-handed tactics towards reporters
police say they fired more than 800
teargas canisters on Monday almost as
many as on all the previous days of
protest combined 148 people were
arrested close to 600 people have been
arrested in weeks of protests which
started against proposed changes to the
extradition law and grew into wider
condemnation of China's control and
allegations of police brutality as for
whether the police wanted support can
Hong Kong police cope with these
protests if they keep going with the
same intensity they have been and if you
can't would you welcome the Chinese army
to come and keep law and order here the
chief executive as well as the
government official had thought really
clearly stated the stance of the
government about the Department of the
PLA so I I do I have anything to
supplement Hong Kong's chief executive
said on Monday that online rumors of PLA
army involvement were aimed at dividing
people
shaking confidence in her government but
she did not rule out ever requesting
military help the streets of Hong Kong
have been Wyatt on Tuesday everyone
protesters and the police is having a
day of relative rest but there will be
protests on Wednesday and at the weekend
many more still Andrew Thomas al Jazeera
Hong Kong